there's a world of evidence both
scientific invites a scientific a not
scientific there's a world of evidence
both hard and anecdotal and bite hard I
can't say hard it's soft it's a softer
sound until you just everything I've
stated is it's hard cellophane baby
hi I'm aria I'm a production assistant
Shane has asked me to read this welcome
to debateable in the interest of a fair
and balanced debate shane has excused
himself from hosting duties he was
unable to remain on the sidelines for
this particular outing are ghosts real
it's debatable
[Music]
go sir you know first off I want to say
you're done you've done a major
disservice to ghosts by dressing them up
in this weird Halloween that's ghost
that's what you believe that is not what
ghost shark I hate the word ghost really
because it's like you think of Casper
I love Casper he's great he's also a
fictional character in a movie it's so
wildly arrogant to think that we have it
all figured out right now there's a lot
of unexplained mysteries in the world go
start one of them we have countless
stories of people that we've no trust
and love who have seen them and felt
them I don't know trust or love it I've
seen it go I'm not sitting here trying
to take a hard percent what are you
trying to say that I'm saying you saying
you never know there's footage of it
there's footage of ghosts caught on
camera there's footage of things moving
on their own you guys got a look into
the YouTube videos I hate the way I
sound right now when I was a kid they
used to be these two guys mm-hmm one was
like short with a hat and one was much
taller and they were friends this sounds
a lot like imaginary friends
we have several EVPs caught on camera
those are disembodied voices EVPs are
the sound of literally anything in a
room going yeah Ryan going
what do you sit on your computer and do
all day I make videos manipulate footage
I'm not believing those YouTube videos
either my man I'm not walking you just
used a YouTube video as evidence it's
happened to me a few times riot where
someone is possible some like an animal
sometimes I'll dream of them I had a
dream about frickin being friends with
Sarah barelli's I never listened to her
music I could go to any 10 random doors
in the world about half of them will say
yeah ghosts are real
half the people in the world think the
Sun revolves around the earth how many
of them just spilled a coffee and we're
like no Sammy Davis jr. is in my living
room you don't get any sort of like oh I
hope my house isn't built on an ancient
burial ground
I grew up across the street from the
cemetery I was never afraid of it baby
boy there's so much evidence when it
comes to scientists a scientific because
it's not scientific its scientific if
they ever reproduce it in a lab I bet
you there's a fair amount of scientists
who believe in God I bet you there's not
but if it is it's probably some [ __ ]
horticulturalist making green beans in a
lab somewhere
to think about his human body but I bet
ghosts are real no one in their right
mind wants to see a ghost unless they're
making money ryan Bergara lots to see a
ghost
I threw a ball down a hallway to had
hundreds literally hundreds of doorways
and windows it lands in a hallway that
has my name painted on it how is that
possibly not evidence you're a little
mind here does it jumps around it
connects all the little dots in a way
that is batshit crazy what you've been
in those moments where you question it
where is just like but what if and
that's the best part about it the
genesis qua of life oh maybe ghosts are
real fun whimsy have you never walked
into a room and been like oh there's
something dark about this place yeah if
there's no lights on I do think it's fun
Halloween is my favorite holiday we're
back but at the end of the day I think a
ghost could come in here pick you up
rock bottom you into this stupid ghost
here and you'd still say what a weird
phenomena there's bear I've asked them
to a thousand times and it won't never
done it yeah because the logistics of
you're weird you're eight feet tall and
we like floppy yes I am fluff but that's
neither here nor there that's kind of
here
you know the difference between Makem
ups in real life don't you the burden of
proof lies upon you and you had nothing
buddy I don't have the facts and figures
in front of me
but how many people die every goddamn
day we live in a surveillance state
houses you set up a little nest cam you
got baby cams everybody's walking around
with cameras in their pocket our
timelines should be flooded with
thousands of ghost pics a day we should
be tired of them we should to be saying
too many ghosts on Instagram now there's
too many ghosts here you're not gonna
find a picture of a ghost on your outfit
of the day pick those people though is
like photos of ghosts you know and
they're like look it's a face I'm like
it's a bit of dusty [ __ ] face every year
that goes on and we don't have any sort
of video or audio proof the case against
ghosts gets stronger and stronger the
amount of ghosts that people have seen
is so small compared to the amount of
people dying thank God because we'd all
be in a constant state of terror or
would we be so used to them because they
were real and we were familiar with them
that we just be like whatever it's okay
Johnny what's up exactly you be like
fist pumping with a ghost but your fist
will go through cuz he's a ghost we're
not seeing this influx of ghost proof
even though should be everywhere
nowadays yeah there could be a ghost
here right now who knows oh look how
funny I thought that was you son of a
[ __ ] you never see it goes just like
hanging out on party like playing
pinball like doing fun things that they
didn't get to do if you came back why
are you just sitting in a chair why
wouldn't you just be freaking and do by
living it up they are there's heaps of
ghosts in Dubai do animals turning the
ghosts yep they do there's a positive
because there's been plenty of sightings
but the monkey goes oh okay are there
yes or no dogs cats birds
how about toads no you can really cut
out a whole file owns trees why would
there be a ghost street why would there
be a ghost
chipmunk because a chipmunk has a soul I
don't think that's a crazy thing to say
a chipmunk probably has a family it has
like a little wife and like two little
chipmunk kids yeah it's fun it's fun
it's fun baby we all know
you guys just go with whatever we're
saying whatever nonsense you're saying I
have to go with it to degree
look I respect what Sarah has said today
all I can do is trust myself and I have
and they are real a lot of the time they
not but they are I think aliens are real
yeah me too the burden of proof falls
upon these these nutcases over here and
I think it's just as much on you to
prove that ghosts aren't real as it is
for me to prove that ghosts are real the
thing is it's not again say with me you
never know I do the arrogance these are
talking about ghosts you get me you get
downright mean look at me yeah yeah this
is insane
[Music]
you don't get any weird vibe from here
in a cemetery that every time you should
be available penalty box and you're it
buster all right
[Music]